يعني السمر يقسم الكثير من من يمارس هذه
السباحه في المياه المتجمده على فوائد هذه
الرياضه الصحيه كثير منهم يعتبرونها رياضه
لكن عامه الناس يرون فيها احد انواع فنون
الجنون يعني لنشاهد هذا المشهد هذه هي
مجموعه من سباحي المياه المتجمده في موسكو
يعني هي مؤسسه رسميه مسجله لدى الاتحاد او
اللجنه الاولمبيه الروسيه كما نشاهد يعني
درجه حراره المياه هي الان تقترب من الصفر
والاحساس العام بالجو يقترب من ناقص 10
درجات درجه حراره المياه هي صفر والاحساس
العام بالجو هو ناقص 10 درجات ثمر
رح يخطف هلا عند الجواد ولا جريء هو بعرف
اكيد راح
ولا لا غيرت رايك بس دير بالك على المايك
يا عبد الجواد مصر
يلا يلا على المايك خايف على المايك طبعا
لابد يعني من تجربه هذا الشيء يعني طيب
يلا انا معكم ليش
راح اشيل السماعه لذلك بدي منك بدي منك يا
ليث ويا سمر تعدوا على التنازلي من الخمسه
عشره تسعه ثمانيه سبعه سته خمسه اربعه
ثلاثه
اثنين واحد تفضل
مباشره في صباح العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
يقفز في مياه بارده
ما بتقدر نكمل معاه بس شوفوا كيف حركه
الجسد مهمه راسا اول ما نط بدو يلعبوا
يتناولوا الطابه الكره
شكله رح يطلع ولا ما راح يطلع ما بعرف راح
يطلع ان شاء الله يطلع خليل عبد الجواد
طلع
يعني شوفوا كيف حلو الموضوع انه شوفوا
اللي بيلعبوا حواليه صاحيين مبكر الساعه
بتوقع تسعه صباحا او 8:00 صباحا في موسكو
ولكن يعني الكل هون رجع عنا
مش معقول
على كل حال شكرا عبد الجواب عبد الجواد
كانت مغامره يعني فريده مباشره على صباح
العربيه هلا نعود الى راويه
مستحيل اعملها انا ميه البحر بدبي بكون
بردانه وما بنزل اعود كميه الف دولار لا
والله
هيك مفاجات وهيك مغامرات بس لما يعملها
بلاقيها سهله هي مش المشكله لما يعملها
المشكله قبل ما يعملها عشان يخلي حاله
يعملها بس والله انه شجاع
مباشره على الهواء